We know that with HTTP,
there are various types of requests
that we can send along with URL.
By default a route in Flask
only answers to get requests.
But that can be changed by providing
the methods argument inside
the route decorator.
I will change my route to
create a new menu item.
Such as a response to GET and
POST requests like so.
Now that I can respond to POST requests,
I can make forms for creating and
updating menu items.
I will make a new template
called newMenuItem.html like so.
Take a second to look over the code.
Here, I'm making a small form with
only one entry to create a new
menu item name.
In order to get data from a form,
I will input requests from my
Flask package like so,
inside my project.py file.
Inside my new menu item function, I will
create an if statement that looks for
a POST request.
I can create a new menu item like so.
And extract the name field from
my form using the request.form.
After I create the menu item,
I can then add it to my session and
commit the session to the database.
To redirect the user back to the main
user page I can use a helper
function called redirect like so.
I should remember to import redirect,
and
url_for, in order to enable this
functionality in my project.
Now, I need to properly handle the get
request, for creating a new menu item.
If my server didn't receive a POST
request, it's going to go ahead and
render the template, for
the new HTML template that I created,
to create a new menu item,
passing in the restaurant_id as well.
Now when I click create new item it
takes me to the New Menu Item page and
I have successfully
created a new menu item